[Musique]
bienvenue à vous de vous retrouver sous
ce soleil printanier Paris Saclay TV
c'est votre magazine toute l'actualité
du territoire alors aujourd'hui on vous
emmène à un groupe ParisTech c'est l'une
des écoles d'agronomie les plus
prestigieuses en France elle a fait sa
rentrée en 2022 ici sur le campus de
Paris Saclay et c'est une formation qui
est vraiment tournée vers l'innovation
et l'entrepreneuriat alors des jeunes
entrepreneurs des entrepreneurs en herbe
qui peuvent compter sur le soutien
l'accompagnement de la French tech Paris
Saclay cette association compte plus de
300 membres elle vient d'être labellisée
capital de la French tech et nous
verrons comment elle accompagne comment
elle permet à ces start-up d'avoir des
financements et d'avoir surtout un très
bon réseau à suivre aussi
chantier ce futur chantier celui d'un
groupe scolaire qui va être donc mise en
place dans le quartier de l'École
polytechnique et la résidence étudiante
Athéna là le chantier bien entamé et ce
sont des bâtiments nouvelle génération
plus respectueux de l'environnement nous
verrons comment enfin l'agenda ce sera
la fin de cette émission
[Musique]
nous voici à gros Paris texte cette
grande école forme les agronomes les
ingénieurs de demain on y réfléchit à
l'agriculture du futur à la nourriture
du futur aussi alors cette grande école
elle s'est installée ici sur ce campus à
la rentrée 2022 elle propose une
formation tournée vers l'innovation et
vers l'entrepreneuriat avec la création
de 15 entreprises par an c'est en
constante évolution rencontre avec
Grégoire burger directeur adjoie en
charge de l'innovation et du transfert
technologique
[Musique]
et l'Institut national des sciences et
industries du vivant et de
l'environnement une école d'ingénieur
spécialisée dans les thématiques très
actuelles que sont le climat
l'environnement l'alimentation durable
les biotechnologies la chimie les
matériaux
l'innovation et l'entrepreneuriat sont
deux grands sujets pour AgroParisTech
étant donné les sujets sur lesquels nous
sommes positionnés et cet accompagnement
prend la forme de deux principaux
dispositifs un premier qui est des jurys
successifs à destination de nos
étudiants de nos diplômés et
éventuellement des enseignants
chercheurs de l'École donc c'est jury
permettent à la fois de faire grandir
les projets et aussi de les soutenir
financièrement à travers deux
partenaires la Fondation AgroParisTech
et agropariste innovation le deuxième
dispositif dédié à l'innovation un
groupe aristech et le réseau des inlabs
qui sont des incubateurs scientifiques
et techniques qui nous permettent
d'aider nos porteurs de projets à
développer des preuves de concept et
donc à se lancer dans l'aventure
entrepreneuriale ces incubateurs sont
thématiques et sont répartis sur les
différents sites d'AgroParisTech le Food
inLab sur le campus de Palaiseau adresse
les problématiques liées à
l'alimentation durable les nouvelles
sources de protéines le packaging donc
les nouveaux emballages les nouveaux
aliments la nutrition le farming Lab est
situé sur la ferme expérimentale
d'AgroParisTech à grignons et nous
permet d'étudier le lien entre
l'agriculture et les nouvelles
technologies numériques l'intelligence
artificielle et la
le biotechnab sur notre campus de Reims
permet d'utiliser les sciences du vivant
pour la production de molécules
d'intérêt pour les secteurs cosmétiques
pharmaceutiques et agroalimentaires et
le forestinglab dédié au sens forestière
sur notre campus de Nancy nous permet
d'étudier et d'accompagner les projets
en lien avec la gestion forestière de
pilotage par satellite et la question
des crédits carbone
[Musique]
agro ParisTech accompagne aujourd'hui
entre 70 et 80 projets de création
d'entreprise nous avons une moyenne de
15 créations d'entreprises par an et
nous voyons que c'est en progression
donc c'est un élément encourageant et ce
sont des projets qui aujourd'hui
marchent bien fonctionnent survivre
après trois ou cinq ans et ce sont aussi
des projets et des entreprises qui
lèvent des fonds puisque en 2022
l'ensemble des projets entrepreneuriaux
d'AgroParisTech on le met un peu plus de
60 millions d'euros
sur le plateau de Saclay et pour nous
une vraie opportunité en matière
d'entrepreneuriat d'innovation dans le
sens où elle nous permet de faire plus
de liens entre la recherche et nos
étudiants porteurs de projets et
également de nous connecter à cette
écosystème de Paris Saclay et à des
partenaires très importants pour nous
notamment comme centrale Supélec nous
avons en effet un programme
d'accompagnement d'accélération commun
twenty first qui nous permet
d'accompagner conjointement des projets
issus des deux établissements
[Musique]
les jeunes pousses de la tête peuvent
compter sur le soutien de la French tech
Paris Saclay cette association est au
service de toutes les startups du
territoire elle compte plus de 300
adhérents elle vient d'obtenir un label
important celui de la capitale de la
French tech une appellation stratégique
alors quel est son rôle comment
peut-elle aider les startups les jeunes
entrepreneurs et bien nous avons
rencontré sa directrice Nadia Benallal
[Musique]
la french tech Paris Saclay rassemble
une communauté de startups on est plus
de 500 startups qui ont un lien avec le
territoire de Paris Saclay et nous
rassemblons maintenant presque 300
adhérents start-up à la french tech
Paris sacrée alors notre vocation
qu'est-ce qu'on propose à ces start-up
c'est bien entendu de les faire
rencontrer entre elles pour qu'elles
puissent partager leur retour
d'expérience et puis bien entendu les
mettre en relation avec tout type
d'acteurs qui peuvent les aider tant sur
le plan administratif que sur le plan
technologique le territoire de Paris
Saclay est un écosystème d'innovation
très riche en effet il rassemble plus de
600 startups plus de 65000 étudiants et
plus de 40 lieux d'innovation alors
qu'est-ce que sont les lieux
d'innovation ce sont toutes les
structures qui accompagnent les startups
tout au long de leur développement la
french tech Paris Saclay est constituée
de deux personnes à temps plein qui
œuvrent tous les jours pour aider ces
startups dans ses mises en relation pour
cela nous proposons aussi plusieurs
programmes qui leur permet d'être aidés
tant sur le plan de financement ou sur
le plan d'accès à des locaux
particuliers sur le territoire et qui
sont bien entendu adapté à leur activité
la french tech Paris Saclay a la chance
d'avoir plusieurs partenaires publics
privés nous concentrons par exemple les
collectivités telles que les communautés
d'agglomération de Paris Saclay 50 ans
en Yvelines et Versailles nous
concentrons également d'autres
partenaires privés tels que des banques
des cabinets de conseils qui nous aident
tous les jours ou quasi tous les jours
en tout cas à proposer des services
adaptés pour ces startups du territoire
au jour le jour la french tech Paris
Saclay aide les startups à être mises en
relation avec des services publics pour
se faire nous avons lancé un programme
qui s'appelle French tech central qui
permet d'accueillir des intervenants des
institutions publiques dans nos locaux
au plagorn à Palaiseau et les startups
peuvent prendre rendez-vous au travers
de notre plateforme qui s'appelle la
french tech centrale de Paris-Saclay
pour permettre de prendre rendez-vous
directement avec ses intervenants
ce programme French tech central permet
ainsi aux start-up d'avoir des réponses
très rapidement à leurs questions sur le
plan administratif grâce au rendez-vous
qu'on propose dans ce bâtiment le
Plédran de Palaiseau la frein chaque
Paris sacrée co-organisée organise des
événements ouverts au public dans lequel
vous aurez la possibilité de rencontrer
des startups je vous invite d'ailleurs à
rejoindre l'événement du 1er juin qui
s'appelle spring et qui aura lieu à HEC
[Musique]
votre territoire se développe se
construit et pour accueillir les
familles qui vont venir s'installer ici
il faut des infrastructures nous sommes
dans le quartier de l'École
polytechnique et un projet de groupe
scolaire est prévu ici même 22 classes
il y aura aussi un centre sportif un
espace de restauration un parking ce
projet confondu par le PA par écrit sa
clé va s'intégrer dans le paysage c'est
une volonté de l'agence Jacques qui a
été choisie regardez
[Musique]
afin d'accompagner le les développements
du quartier de l'École polytechnique le
PA Paris Saclay et réalise pour le
compte de la ville de Palaiseau le futur
groupe scolaire du quartier c'est un
projet qui est inscrit au programme des
équipements publics de la ZAC afin
d'accompagner les besoins générés par
l'arrivée des nouvelles familles sur le
quartier à l'horizon 2025 l'équipement
comprend donc un groupe scolaire de 22
classes 12 classes élémentaires 8
classes maternelles et deux classes
rotules donc des classes qui sont qui
sont là pour en faire face à l'évolution
du besoin et on a également au sein de
cet équipement un certain nombre de
programmes mutualisés que sont notamment
un espace de restauration de l'accueil
périscolaire un gymnase en
complémentarité avec un pôle sportif de
quartier qui est on réalise également à
proximité directe de ce groupe scolaire
le futur équipement sportif est réalisé
dans ce qu'on appelle le secteur sud du
quartier à proximité de la toute
nouvelle résidence étudiante à cœur
house
c'est également un secteur qui donc est
situé à proximité directe des coteaux
boisés outre les enjeux de polyvalence
et d'évolativité qui auquel le projet
doit répondre une attention toute
particulière et portée sur la qualité
des espaces extérieurs support de
biodiversité en connexion directe avec
les lisières du plateau toutes proches
en effet tous les espaces extérieurs
donc les cours de la maternelle en
rez-de-chaussée de l'élémentaire à
l'étage mais également les toitures
végétalisées et le jardin potager tous
ces éléments doivent répondre à une
démarche de cour oasis permettant à la
fois de lutter contre les îlots de
chaleur mais également de pouvoir offrir
de véritables espaces pédagogiques
appropriable par les élèves les équipes
enseignantes et les familles
le bâtiment la particularité d'avoir 60%
de sa structure en bois ce qui est un
défi conséquent quand on sait la
complicité d'avoir des cours d'étages en
soccer bois et donc tout ce travail est
mené de front pour justement relier les
complexités techniques qu'il y a avec
l'action de construction bois avec
justement ce sujet des cours la
végétalisation et des corauxistes le
projet s'inscrira également dans une
démarche de label BDF donc bâtiment
concilier durable et ses vertura obtenir
tous les labels environnementaux
nécessaires pour un groupe scolaire
remarquable et actuellement
nous avons quitté le quartier de l'École
polytechnique pour celui de moulons avec
un chantier plus avancé vous l'aurez
noté celui de la résidence étudiante
Athéna à terme plus de 300 logements
alors là aussi c'est un bâtiment
nouvelle génération plus respectueux de
l'environnement la structure est en bois
notamment et ce bâtiment il a été conçu
comme un bateau avec des espaces
partagés nous allons faire une vidéo
avec Christophe ouayou cofondateur de
cause architectes
je vous présente aujourd'hui la
résidence Athena
cette résidence étudiante elle est sans
doute une génération nouvelle de
bâtiments des bâtiments qui sont
décarbonés d'abord
qui visent une grande biodiversité dans
leur conception ce grand jardin nous
permet aussi de faire un recueil des
eaux pluviales à la parcelle de recréer
la biodiversité dans ce lieu central on
l'a un peu conçu comme un navire c'est
un grand bateau il fait plus de 120
mètres de long et 13 mètres de large et
il y aura 300 étudiants hébergés là dans
des cabines alors pas comme des cabines
de bateaux puisque la conception est un
peu particulière c'est une série
d'appartements donc il y a 300 plus de
300 hébergements et qui sont regroupés
en une quarantaine de d'appartements
donc chaque appartement 2 à 2 dans une
système de grandes courses de coursive
vertical
regroupe une grande une grande terrasse
commune qu'on a appelé un plongeoir qui
est en balcon sur ce grand jardin à
l'ouest dans lequel ils pourront
échanger
la deuxième caractéristique c'est que ce
qui en fait un paquebot et une sorte de
grande croisière c'est qu'ils ont plus
de 500 mètres carrés d'espace partagé
essentiellement localisé au
rez-de-chaussée donc dans sa conception
c'est un bâtiment qui est construit
majoritairement en bois ce qui fait son
son fameux bilan carbone il est
entièrement conçu on le voit avec un
système de poteau poutre bois et ensuite
des planchers en béton
il est à la fois construit en bois et en
béton est très préfabriqué c'est à dire
que c'est des éléments qui arrivent
montés pour la plupart ils sont
assemblés ici rapidement ça ça baisse
aussi le niveau de disons de nuisances
qu'on impose à un lieu qui est déjà très
habité et en même temps c'est le c'est
le système qui nous permet d'avoir une
vraie qualité constructive la
particularité ce bâtiment c'est qu'on a
implanté de manière très très économe
sur le sur la parcelle on a plus de 60%
de la parcelle qui nous était dévolu qui
a été rendu en pleine terre boisé qui
nous permet d'infiltrer de l'eau et de
se limiter dans sa phase constructive ok
il y a ce côté très frugal dans son
implantation sur le site ça je pense que
c'est aussi une des caractéristiques
importantes de ce lieu on est implanté
dans un lieu qui est absolument
magnifique qui est boisé qui est déjà
constitué qu'on voulait préserver
absolument dans son identité dans sa
force et je pense que demain ce lieu va
devenir un lieu assez festif pour les
étudiants et en même temps très
qualitatif dans la qualité de vie
[Musique]
notre agenda présent nous évoquions des
chantiers à venir ou en cours votre avis
est important venez participer à la
concertation préalable relative à la ZAC
gare de Guyancourt 50 ans quartier des
Savoie on entre dans la troisième phase
avec l'organisation de nouvelles balades
urbaines en mars et en avril plus
d'informations sur le site
EPS.fr visitez le premier showroom
technologique mutualisé du cluster
d'innovation Paris-Saclay et faites
connaissance avec les startups qui vont
façonner le monde de demain c'est le 23
mars mais attention la réservation est
obligatoire à noter aussi le retour de
start-up for kids ce sera du dimanche 16
au lundi 17 avril cette cinquième
édition se déroule dans la prestigieuse
école de centralesupélec c'est agile sur
Yvette postulez pour animer des ateliers
pendant un ou deux jours vous avez
jusqu'au 28 février pour postuler et
vous l'avez certainement déjà noté
Paris-Saclay spring c'est le 1er juin à
HEC c'est la sixième édition et comme
toujours pour tous les acteurs de
l'innovation de la recherche et de la
science sont invités avec toujours le
même objectif donner à voir l'excellence
scientifique et le meilleur de
l'innovation technologique les
inscriptions aux écoles d'été de Ath
unife sont ouvertes vous êtes élève en
4e et vous êtes libre du 26 autres fin
juin et bien venez rencontrer les
chercheurs les chercheuses de
l'université et découvrir leurs
recherches dans leur laboratoire qui
sait vous aurez peut-être la vocation et
voilà j'espère que vous avez tout bien
noté c'est la fin de cette émission
merci encore de l'avoir suivie on se
retrouve très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de Paris-Saclay TV
[Musique]